in five four three two one
that was loud is it Ohio hello everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast this is actually kind of
late at night and since I did this pot
yes at my crib I decided to have the
lady back on again
hi you know when we do these podcast is
interesting because I generally don't
know what direction to go when I do this
right
but I feel like the direction that I
should take when it comes to you and I
don't know why this podcast is becoming
more and more like this but it seems to
be more and more about relationships and
how like having to deal with like social
situations
so I have you on because oh by the way
this would need the poop pillow that I
have next to me is it is something that
I got for her and you look like him
right now with that red shirt oh because
he's yellow and Asian you racist how can
I be racist racist I don't care you're
internally racist it's kill I have this
covered because I don't want to show my
penis but everyone okay so one of the
things that I know that
well actually this was something that
somebody sent and they kind of wrote
they were asking how to be vulnerable
with your with your partner or the
person that you're with oh yeah why was
it a hoiy because it's it's hard I mean
we went through a lot to open up each
other and told us anything is pretty
hard we've learned you I think so it's
just opening talking about your feelings
is one thing but how to express so that
the partner understands rather than
getting emotionally attacked or like
misunderstanding is hard yeah I mean
well this person kind of I don't have my
phone next to me well actually I do but
I'm too lazy to look through it but they
were they were saying that it's hard for
them to open up to their partner and the
other person is really hard to open up
to them you know I have us I have a
friend to who I just saw not too long
ago and she was at telling me about her
problems with with her current boyfriend
number one they are they are years
they're like 10 years apart or something
right
I might have had that no
but they it's for them it's very
difficult because number one they're -
they're too similar so how they approach
how they communicate with each other is
the exact same but not in the does that
seem like they clash they they clash
because they think the same but in the
sense that both of them don't like to
open up to each other and so they kind
of just expect things to fall into place
and so what she was telling me was that
they have this problem of they just
everything is very surface right or when
there are problems none of them open up
to each other so things kind of come up
passive-aggressively so for example do
you remember when we started going out
and I always like to mention this
because I think I don't think it's the
fact that you I don't know if this has
to do with vulnerability but one of the
one of the behaviors that I really
didn't like that I think that you
probably had an issue with when we first
started was passive aggressiveness
uh-huh right because you said that you
didn't you didn't like getting angry
yeah but I would bring it up in a
different way yeah that's well to be
fair I would say it's not common to have
someone to make you feel so sensitive
about everything that you sometimes you
just don't know how to take that in and
understand and execute what you need to
do and I think how would I make you feel
sensitive it's just you know certain
things that friends would say it doesn't
bother me but when you say it it's like
a whole different meaning it's just like
all these questions come into my head
like what is that supposed to mean like
what does it mean by that doesn't not
like it anymore - like is he judging me
now like you know there's just so many
questions that comes around it's like
Mariel what is going on like I don't
know about what it says emotion is just
like starts gathering up and all these
like emotions just come in and out and
at that moment you just don't know what
to do and you're just like agitated
because you can't figure it out and I
think that's what happened to me is that
it's not that I want to be I can't
express being mad it's just I didn't
know what to do and so it there was it
just came out in a different way it was
weird because I you know because we're
very
pressive people right especially when it
came to joy and you know when we first
started going out everything is very
happy it's it's it's very much that
honeymoon phase and when you're in that
honeymoon phase everything is just when
you walk around it's beautiful and yeah
we're walking through Skid Row and all
the time that we just see this dandelion
in the cracks and look at this beautiful
flower in this crack like jasmine no it
smells like flowers over here look at
that blob piss well that person had a go
it's okay it's beautiful but you know as
we you know do you remember when we
first started going out how you how I
said what could possibly go wrong we
fight about we're always so happy I
laughed in your face that was so funny
to me that's what I mean it's just I
didn't know what to expect I didn't know
that a person would make me feel so
angry and so sad and so happy like you
were the first one who actually made me
feel that way
oh that thing yeah but it took a while
and I'm really glad that you had the
patient to walk with me on this just how
to emot-- that expression because it was
very it was soup I mean it was hard for
you it was it was hard for me and I
think because your family and my family
are they're very different right so
you've been around my mom and dad
they're so expressive
they don't really hide their feelings at
all you know if my mom is upset if my
mom is happy its riddled all over her
face and she doesn't even her passive
aggressiveness isn't really that passive
yeah it's pretty [ __ ] aggressive yeah
so until this day you parents when they
get into argument they express it yeah
where my family doesn't really do that I
don't think I mean they used to but I
think they figured I it's just a
different way to cope it's like your
parents they need to say it
to let it out whereas my parents is like
they need alone time to let the heat go
down there was a funny moment where um
so Muriel was a very hard person for to
figure out number one she didn't have
the like long-term relationship
experience so she dated a lot but she
didn't have a like a boyfriend
boyfriend at this time when I met her
now mind you like I you know when I
first saw her I was you know I was kind
of smitten I thought she was this super
fun girl was is she's a super fun girl
yeah I'm not trying to get my ass beat
up this podcast a super fun girl just
very easygoing
um which she is and you know she was
then and she still is now but the thing
that I wasn't prepared for now mind you
I don't know I when she told me that she
didn't actually have a boyfriend or a
very serious relationship before um it
wasn't something that I was expecting
right and I guess expect no I just
thought that you've dated at least
somebody but or you like you had a
serious relationship before you know and
mind you like I met you when I was what
26 and you were what 25 yeah so you were
25 I was 26 we were I see I see what
you're talking about yeah you know what
I mean yeah so I had more of a
light-weighted
relationship yeah and so I didn't know
what to expect and all the things that
came with that package right so I didn't
know that I had to have the patience to
understand that number one a lot of the
first stuff a lot of the first
relationship stuff you did an experience
yeah and so you know I felt that I kind
of was ill-prepared uh in that sense
because you didn't know like for example
you you didn't even have your first
couple fight you didn't have oh there
was nothing none of that you've ever had
you're you're the first boyfriend gave
you flowers the first anniversary the
first month thing there was a lot of
things that you didn't do that I had to
re-experience I felt like I was in high
school again you know in a good and that
way at the same time because a part of
me was kind of like look she just up
because I already didn't like this big
but only because I felt bad that it
didn't feel it felt amazing and it was
great because it was with you but I felt
like I couldn't match that same energy
because I it was yours
it was truly your first first you know
and and sometimes I felt like I would
ruin those experiences because it wasn't
it wasn't maybe what you
I couldn't match the expectation that
you had for what you wanted in that
first experience
I feel like you did well hmm I don't I
can't recall anything that was like
disappointing for anything of our first
like you know I always wanted to go to
Disneyland with my like serious
relationship guy and you happen to be
that person got our Disneyland that was
so fun little did I know that wasn't
gonna happen again no we went a lot
though we did we went like seven times
at least we did it wasn't I mean I'm
glad that we did that when were younger
because if I because we went from like
morning till after midnight it closed
yeah and it was New Year's Eve and I was
super crowded oh that's the first time
was New Year's yeah it was so crowded
and I don't know how we walked all day
because it was a hell of fat - you were
you were in the midst of losing weight
but you were bigger back then you're
skinny man but yeah like I that was that
was an amazing day and that was the day
where I told my people be like hey you
know it's whoo-hoo my boyfriend is and
um I mean I wouldn't able to do that now
if you ask me or if I asked you like
there's no way that's gonna happen -
zoom was such a weird thing for me being
and I mentioned this before on JK news
work the way she experiences Disneyland
and the way that I still have our two
[ __ ] different things my childhood
playground
I know it's your childhood playground
but for me I can't wrap my head around
the fact that number one you've been
there four thousand times why does it
feel like you've never been there before
every time you walk in you beak I think
it's this thing it's this fantasy of you
go in and you're not this adult with
lots of responsibilities you go in as a
kid and kid who has this fantasy of it
you know all these fairies and
imaginations and just like going back
into your childhood memory that's what
it feels like to me like I'm going
inside a dream that's insane I always
say this I remember when I walked in and
I walked in and I saw this girl she just
like skipping around with like I feel
like when you go to Disneyland what
happened like you walk in and then what
you picture is goofy comes up the Eagles
gawrsh
hi there bear
real and then Tinkerbell comes down she
boots you on the nose Boop hello she
flies away and you're like Tinkerbell
that's your reality those are your
goggles and then for me I see chip paint
old paint baby crying a couple fighting
over here all these crowds like pushing
me so don't you want like to be
yeah but Disney that wasn't a part of my
childhood though Disney was yeah so you
see that happening like embracing
everything like oh this is so magical
yeah but I didn't have that connection
like you had like you had with Disney
because my thing was yeah I saw Aladdin
I saw Lion King I saw a sword in the
stone like these were I mean they were
childhood films but I didn't sit there
and just you know if there was like a
ninja turtle world I bet you I freaked
the [ __ ] out really yeah but then they
would have to put that in the sewers or
my smell about that but for you yeah I
don't have that same experience well I
think it's also because I worked there
when I was in high school and I don't
know middle school like my parents used
to take me there with my friends and it
was you know cheaper back then and then
high school I worked there so there's a
lot of memory that comes with it but I
think yeah it's just the whole like
childhood memory just going inside it's
like a dream it's like you open a closet
and it's like all setting you're in a
different world
you usually get Chronicles of Narnia I
mean just to go back to the whole being
vulnerable thing I think that you would
take anything with Disney to heart for
example do you remember when I had first
of all we had this it was this weird
feeling because we went to Disneyland
this is the last time with the
Disneyland I I was sick with the fever
yeah remember I was sick with the fever
we took a picture or whatever and I
thought we were having a good time to
the best of my ability I thought we were
having a good time to the best of my
ability I mean I felt something was a
little off and then on the on the car
ride home I asked you I was like I was
like hey I actually had a pretty good
time and you go and I was looking at you
like what do you mean and I had a good
time and you just you know you just
didn't seem as happy as I wanted you to
be I was like what do you mean happy as
I let me enjoy busy the way I want to
enjoy Disney while they enjoyed
because I want to skip around and you
were just like with us well we didn't
know he had a fever you were getting
better if you had fever we could have
stayed home I did you knew I was sick
before we left we thought you were
getting better and I was and I started
getting better towards the last like
couple hours well either way ah cuz I
when I go to Disneyland
you know usually with my girlfriends or
whatever like we just skip around I mean
II see Johnson girlfriend like she skips
around twirls around just have a great
time
did you guys are you guys are sick
freaks like no well that's your girl man
runs in the family you guys like that I
mean you're just sitting around spitting
up when we were in Paris - we went to
Paris Disneyland it was raining and then
she she goes can you record me can you
record me I was like doing what she goes
I'm gonna spin she's just like it was
fun it was a freshman it's so funny
because in my world I'm my imagination I
was like jumping around really high like
singing in the rain and look at the
video do you look crazy like I have a
huge hump on my back and just like oh
yeah I mean yeah but you know I have to
say that recently it's just been it's
been kind of a different I don't know
why I think it's because that time I was
my first time working at Disney
it was everything was first you know
like I was working I was going in there
as an employee working at the studio
mm-hmm and I think there was this
butterfly of like everything being first
I can't believe I'm here
yeah as a you know employee and I'm
bringing my friends or family for free
all the perks that you get out of it but
this round
I don't know I'm more alike I feel like
I'm a little bit retired from that do
you feel like you were tired from doing
I still love going there but I'm not as
energetic anyways cuz I'm hate I mean
that was you know to be fair like four
or five years ago yeah so now I'm like I
gotta save my energy cycle but that was
also your first with your first you know
your very first serious boyfriend you
got to go to
was something that you were dreaming
about and Albia ty didn't meet your
expectation of what you want like a
Disney boyfriend I think you did well my
first own when we went to Disney for the
first time but they in the last round
are just like you know what you know he
did it for the past four years yeah and
then you went with your friends and you
find out oh maybe I'm not even into it
as much as I used to be yeah I got old
but to go back to the being you know the
whole going off but you know being
vulnerable
with you was very hard and it was hard
for you oh yeah it was super hard
specifically because um you've never
felt what if you don't know what it
feels like to be in love dumb I was way
off you don't like to have your heart
broken and even even Gio doesn't know
what it's like to be dumped she's never
been dumped before now mind you I bought
them on the same level as Gio oh shut up
but we when I when I when I was will see
how old was I was at 19 years old so
when I was 19 years old I had my very
first heartbreak I got dumped for the
very first time in my life and it's
crazy because during that moment when
you get your heart broken right not
everything in though especially as a 19
year old kid everything at that moment
feels like hell like this feeling of
having your heart broken will at that
moment will never pass it just won't
pass it's impossible every day you wake
up and you open your eyes and you don't
want to open your eyes anymore like I
remember laying in bed crying my eyes
out because this woman loves me but you
know and the reason why was because
during that time you know I I went
through this whole period of having a
very low self-esteem right I mean we can
go into a litany of reasons why but she
at that time because I didn't really
value myself as a person and I didn't
know who I was what I was doing who I
wanted to be I kind of put my whole
existence into this girl so if that's a
very that's
of course and I was young at the time
too so if she told me I was worth
something I was worth something if she
told me I was a good person I'm a good
person if she said I was a bad person I
was a bad person and I just I was so
emotionally volatile at the time
why were you like that before you met
her like why is it that you didn't have
yourself like a confident identity I
just I just didn't like myself I didn't
like you didn't like yourself I don't
think I liked myself I didn't know what
I was doing I didn't I I had you know
trouble in my household because you know
I wasn't like my older brother my
brother was very academic he did really
well in school I did terrible in school
I'll be it I did really well on my SATs
but that was the only accomplishment
that I had in school you know when you
graduated high school and people would
have all these like tassels and the
nothing and my brother had a bunch of
sashes I had absolutely nothing I just
wanted to get the hell out of high
school and so when this girl came around
and mind you she was well I consider her
my best friend as a girl my girl best
friend she was everything to me she
could having her around made me feel
good and so I chased that feeling and so
when she was around I was happy and I
and for me I wanted to hold on to that
happiness so hard so I didn't want her
to go anywhere I was the worst type of
boyfriend ever I was extremely jealous
I was very clingy I wanted to talk to
her on the phone like four or five hours
a night you know and when I left the
college so I went to UCR she went to
Davis at the time and um you know what I
look back on it I we don't have anything
in common really like she and I are come
two completely different people but
because she was my identity she meant
everything to me so she went to you I
want to use she or she went to Davis and
I hated I hated you see her I don't want
to go there yeah I hated it so the only
thing I can hold on to was that every
night she and I would talk on the phone
and she would make me feel good and so
when she broke up with me my existence
just might might my my identity
shattered because she was my identity
which was the worst thing you could ever
[ __ ] do I can't imagine what that's
like because I've never not that I had
like confidence of myself or anything
but to the fact that where you're
hanging on to someone else so
are to have an identity that sounds
scary yeah I mean I was a 19 year old
kid with low self-esteem
yeah I didn't know what to do you know
and she was the one that actually helped
me feel better about myself so you know
it kind of goes hand in hand and so when
she left that she decided to leave and
I'll be it she made a great choice it's
like a part of me I it if I would
describe the physical feeling the
physical manifestation of what it felt
like to be dumped at 19 it was like
somebody ripped my heart out of my chest
and just had it sink into the bottom of
my stomach and it felt like my stomach
was turning mmm that's what it felt like
and I could still remember what that
feels like today how did you cope with
it
why do you think I know so much cried
midnight yo I know Brian McKnight songs
because I got dumped so much that's how
we click to remember in our first thing
you turn it on and I was like oh my gosh
I love that one was it it was I think
you had back at one even though that's
like your least favorite yeah cuz and
that's my favorite no it was six eight
twelve was it no I swear was back out
one we should be together that's back at
one mmm oh that is right yeah yeah yeah
so we had um yeah and so after she left
me I think number one there was a couple
of life left life lessons that I had
from that number one I learned how big
of a [ __ ] loser I was I learned that
how much the reason why I was a loser is
because I put all of myself into some
into a woman or at the time a girl for
what like what what would that I've done
you know I mean she leaves I'm left with
nothing
I wasn't seen the bright midnight boys
Tim it you know what the song that I had
spinning on boys to men was the most was
um on a perfect day you know that I can
count on you that one and you have this
thunder and rain in the back and I would
just sit there
I know oh my god you're such an emo tell
me can you were you like the main
character kdrama
just like looking all handsome crying
well I wasn't handsome I was disgusting
and I still had discussed until this day
but then I was worse and thank you
sweetie she said you don't like
discussing cuz I date you or I know but
I I I remember after that I mean just to
fast-forward and we can we could talk
about this part just cuz hasn't doesn't
have anything to do with the topic of
this podcast today but being vulnerable
after that was very hard because I was
so scared of feeling that way yeah I
want to protect yourself of course and I
never ever ever ever ever wanted to feel
that way again and so after I dated her
I dated other people who just weren't my
type yeah and the reason why I wanted to
date somebody who wasn't my type and I
started dating anybody and everybody
that would have me just because I told
myself that this person was the one as
an 18 17 16 year old boy so I had a huge
crush on are started from sophomore year
of high school and I got the girl my
high school crush I finally got her so
she was I was like I don't know who I am
which means I don't know what I like and
I think this was really definitively the
onslaught of me starting to invoke this
thing in my life I was like you don't
know what you like until you try it
because I was so I made my mind up so
much the point that I thought that this
one type of girl was my person and she
wasn't I wasn't gonna make that mistake
again so I decided to date anybody in
anybody anybody and everybody and so I
wasn't no we just dated you know my I
didn't you know this about me I didn't
sleep around a lot it wasn't my thing
and I don't think a lot of women wanted
to sleep with me at the time so for me
it was just I would date and then if the
person wasn't somebody that I'd like
that just kind of cut it off I'd be like
um you know we you know we get along but
it so you just wanted to day on the
surface surface or if it went further
and then we hooked that we did but it
wasn't it wasn't a goal I had in mind I
think compared to leave to a lot of my
guy friends I wasn't as sexually active
or sexually driven
a lot of my friends when they were
younger I think they would always talk
about [ __ ] sex getting girls banging
them yes I'm sucking your dicks and
stuff and for me I would just sit there
awkwardly just laughing like ha ha ha
because I just wanted to fall in love I
wanted to fall in love and so oh you
found the right girl and you were the
first girlfriend I'm kidding she's dead
to me but uh now she's a she's a she's a
sweet girl but um yeah I just was so
afraid of of being that way yeah and
then you are by far my number one my my
longest relationship yeah I think my
should be the longest it is you I said
by far my longest relationship you're
the longest relationship you're the most
successful and you I have you are the
one that I've been the happiest with for
sure that's why I'm still here
and so having to go through the stage
and I didn't realize that since then
when I was 18 or 19 20 whatever or
during those times that I was dating
people and I was just dropping just kind
of pushing people away I didn't realize
that I had this vulnerability barrier
you know and I started noticing this
when um a couple years down the line
where I could I mean when I was next to
you and I knew that I loved you I could
tell you that I love you right
but you would ask me stuff like um text
me in the morning you know and you know
I didn't want to text you in the morning
like good morning I didn't want to do it
uh-huh and the honest reason why is
because when I look back at it now is
because it made me vulnerable
why because I would have to show you
this side that I care all the time and
it wasn't a card that I got to keep to
myself like I'll show you how much I
care when I want to but if I have to do
that then I oh that means that at this
set moment in time every time I wake up
during the day I have to show you how
vulnerable I am good morning sweetie and
it was hard for me though you never told
me about this well I only realized this
probably maybe like a year or so ago
and because I couldn't you know there's
times where I sit at night you know I
have insomnia and so I kind of think
about these things like you know why
couldn't I just do that and I you know
when I think back on it now is because I
was just scared
like I didn't want to give you that
because you're afraid I was gonna dump
you or that's really what it is because
it's like you kind of give
when you're vulnerable you give somebody
this this this opening tip yeah you yeah
and it's this fear of like oh [ __ ] am I
gonna let this person do this again am I
gonna have to be that 18 that 19 20 year
old kid that was crying in his bed again
and that's the part that's scary and I
think that's also the scary part of
marriage this is very part of committing
to somebody and having these kids
because you also have to commit to the
fact that once this person takes your
heart takes everything with that what
takes everything with them there's a
chance that they might leave what if
they die what if they you know these
kind of things go through my head but I
kind of stopped myself from being I kind
of stopped opening myself to you in fear
of what I was gonna lose rather than
focusing on what I had wow I didn't know
I think you were just open book I'm you
know buddy you already get time to time
I'd be like do we just do it and be like
no I'm like wow I couldn't do it but it
knows because you're afraid I you're
gonna get hurt I mean well you you I
think you were at you had issues with
being vulnerable too oh yeah absolutely
yeah cuz you couldn't like I said you
couldn't even get in you would pretend
like you weren't mad well I think dad I
don't know if it's vulnerable maybe it
is but it was just a different door that
I was never I never had to open up you
know like I would never have to scream
or yell at my parents you sound like I
have siblings I've never dealt with that
kind of conflicts with friends more or
less because we don't have to go to that
level so I think it's just more of like
I don't first of all I don't like Kelly
I think that's just like very tiresome
and the fact that I had to do that it
felt I guess so it is vulnerable cuz
then it's just like oh I'm doing
something that I just don't want to be
part of I mean you it was weird because
I thought the the oddest thing about you
when we first know we were getting into
fights was you arguably when you were
enraged and you felt said you wanted to
cry but you always wanted to hold back
your tears because you didn't want you
did want to let me see you cry because I
think that for you it was like if I let
this guy see me cry i'ma show them that
I'm weak
crying is a definitely my weak point I
hate crying I hate cry in front of
anyone but then yeah if I show that I'm
crying in front of you ooh
felt like I lost the game you know the
first you know I remember the first time
you actually bawled in front of me you
you actually don't ball in front of me
just like teary but no this is you
actually crying you when it was when we
when I was living in the k-town spot
uh-huh and you already opened up to me
the fact that you there's a period in
your life where you gained a lot of
weight and you didn't like yourself
image and this is when I was bigger and
I was trying to lose weight by doing
macros and you didn't understand what
macros were I don't know whether you
believed it in or not or or whatever you
didn't like my methodology so I would
put in my macros and I was losing weight
through you know just managing my fat
calories and whatever right and it was
working here and there but then I was I
don't know what happened with the way we
were communicating back in the day but
even when we got into an argument but I
remembered what the feeling that I took
away from it from the argument was that
you were making it difficult for me to
really love myself and you were hurting
my self-image and I remember what I said
to you was that I said you should know
what it feels like to be overweight and
not not like the way you look but
however you felt then is how you make me
feel when you talk to me about my weight
and then you got really quiet and then
you just started tearing up and you went
and you started balling while you were
laying in my bed you were balling and
then you know after you're crying I
couldn't figure out why y'all say what
they feel bad about your way yeah why
what was I saying you just I think you
were just and this was before this is
not when you were the biggest no this
was like a year into our relationship
and you just I remember you crying
because you felt that you were being a
bully and then you were you were kind of
hurting my self-image
a lot had already just bawling your eyes
up you remember that I
remember that you were crying that was
the first time I ever saw you just
full-out cry in front of me holy cow how
come I don't remember this but it must
been a really good girl to cry because I
felt bad for being a bully that I didn't
really I felt really bad but you've
never ever since then you never really
mentioned anything about my weight you
know to tell you the truth I grew up
mice around like my friends or anyone
yeah my sir my friends or the guys who
I've dated I have to say I didn't have
everybody was fairly active I didn't
have anyone who was big or just
overweight overweight just inactive just
yeah we care too much activity it was
actually a shock that I was with a fat
guy love with this guy who I'm just like
I don't know if I'm I honestly I was
like I don't know if I'm physically
attracted to this oh [ __ ] okay well that
hurts no no but that was true that's
true that's true they probably that's
why it seeped out like that because I've
never dated anyone who was overweight so
I was like this is weird I don't know
why I'm still dating this guy because I
think I really enjoyed your personality
yeah and I think that was most girls
maybe and I was trying to see you like
if I this is gonna last and honestly
yeah I think that's what it is for both
of us like for the first at least a year
or two like we were seeing if we were a
match for each other
yeah and the first year it was a
struggle for me I don't think I've ever
told you about like I was just not sure
if I was going to be fully committed to
this relationship because I don't know
if I was attracted to you oh really
completely what what just because of the
physical part yeah because physically I
just wasn't sure if I was attracted to
you now it's a different story
like I well I guess like physically if
you didn't feel physically attracted me
you sure as hell kiss me a lot not the
first year first year yeah yeah yeah I
don't know
well that's a thing it was like slowly
gradually as the more I got to know you
the more that didn't become apparent
more do you feel like back then when you
were younger you were maybe a little bit
too focused on looks
no shell oh I think so because I didn't
know who you were yeah I was getting to
know you and I liked what I was seeing
on the inside but I was like but it
wasn't enough for me to not think about
physical attraction yeah I feel a lot of
people get weirded out when somebody
says then for me when you tell me that
like I'm not even offended by that and I
understand because I think that
sometimes when you are it's too late
it's too late we've been together for
such a long time but I feel like when
people sometimes hear that they you know
they get disappointed an individual who
says things like that openly but you
know physical attraction is a huge part
of being in a relationship and I'm not
saying that's for everybody some people
they go it's never about looks cool
that's for you some people that physical
attraction part matters it matters and I
eat even matters for me too I'm not
gonna lie even though I look like a sea
monster I still wanted to be with a
pretty person you look like my Pooh Bear
oh now I do yeah you know and I think
for you it's big for me I mean I can't
speak for you but if I were to interpret
it's because you were so active and you
were so adamant about your health like
there's a certain point where you're
just making all healthy recipes and it
was something that made you happy and I
was something that you couldn't share
with me yeah you know and it probably
made you sad too that there's somebody
who like a representation of like maybe
for you my dedication or non dedication
to fitness was also representation that
I didn't care about myself and so and I
understand and I didn't care about
myself in that sense like I didn't care
enough about how being overweight was
affecting me you know and even even now
you even know this too I didn't notice
this until you mentioned it when when I
lost even the first 30 pounds my
attitude was different this round this
round oh yeah you know I didn't know
that I didn't know how much how man you
have no idea how hard it was when you
were at your max weight when I wasn't
what two years ago now yeah how come you
never well I guess it's hard to mention
it right I mean I mean you didn't
mention it but yeah I didn't mention it
but it wasn't I think that year was
probably one of the hardest emotion I
was kind of hard because you were going
through a lot with your career and that
was affecting
your health and I could clearly see the
correlation between those two and wasn't
miserable you were yeah and you were
trying so many things and like I
couldn't tell you to stop anything
because I don't have an answer for you
and eating was your way to relief your
stress and that all I could do was just
kind of be there for you because you
weren't gonna listen to anyone either
way you have to go through it realize
that what you what you like and when you
don't like and I was just there for you
regardless and it was kind of hard for
me because I could see that you're going
down with your health and I was like
concerned about that but I think once
you have realized it and you know
towards the end of the year I did tell
you like how I felt about you know how
you're doing with your health and like
your work in our quality time like you
rarely had time for us and so I you know
I could see that you were becoming very
weak and I couldn't become weak with you
I couldn't go along with that like I so
I had to be the stronger end right and
so you know I got to the point where
it's like I think we need to sit down
and talk about this and what I realized
is that even though that was your
biggest weight which if I look at it
again right now like it's just look like
me it is amazing how much I did not see
that to like I saw that you were gaining
a lot of weight but I didn't see I was
like disgusting person I saw you I was
like someone who's trying super hard to
make things work yeah and I wanted to be
there for you yeah and I realized that's
when I hit me I was like I don't think I
really care about like whether he's big
or not like I just want to make sure
that he's happy you know and when she
says like disgusting - it's not it's not
big you know like the fat would make me
disgusting it was my behavior yeah how I
carried myself my attitude there was
just a lot of things that were just
going downhill and you know I couldn't
and even then - it was hard for me to be
vulnerable with you because I wanted to
be a strong figure in your life you know
I wanted to be the strong boyfriend and
I didn't want to show you that side
either and you know for me to be honest
with you the person that probably helped
me I mean you and Vanessa were the two
biggest people that helped me lose the
weight the most right because Vanessa if
you guys don't know who vanessa is
vanessa is my was my former assistant
sweetest girls so sweet and she I call
her my assistant she's like my baby
sister I loved this girl too she was one
of those people that just had to she had
to deal with my [ __ ] the most she was
there throughout the whole thing and
there was a point where I was just
giving her a paycheck just to help me
just to be around and just do [ __ ] for
me like I didn't need her to do it but I
was so it wasn't such a rut I just
needed her dudes I couldn't get out of
bed you were spread and I was spread so
thin you know I was trying to do the
acne just it was just so much you know
and I knew that you didn't want to show
your weakness okay like I know that you
were tire exhausted but you don't want
to show that so I'm just there kind of
just being there yeah being your
girlfriend being the girl who you know
you want to get out of that stress so
you know you come to me or you come you
go to Vanessa and I just that's all I
wanted to do for you and that's all I
could do
yeah which was really hard it was hard I
think it affected a lot of people you
know big huge parts of my relationship
like quality time was the hardest thing
I was just so distracted I didn't and I
was trying to distract myself with
anything and everything to avoid the
fact that I was gaining weight I wasn't
feeling good and I just didn't I didn't
know what to do you know well I I
mentioned this under earlier podcast but
I listened to this podcast with Joe
Rogan where they had this guy named
David Goggins on there and David Goggins
his former Navy SEAL he I mean his story
is insane but basically he was 300
pounds he was heavier than I was and he
he actually failed going into the
military multiple times and he his story
was so inspiring and I think the thing
that hit me the most was hit what he
told me was you're not you kind of just
a lot of people just kind of race
against other people but they never you
know kind of race against themselves
yeah
so you're don't be the best at what
other people tell you to be be the best
that you can be and then kind of measure
yourself with that and it was and he
kind of had this done it's like are you
happy he goes are you really happy
mm-hmm
you know are you happy being this person
you know can you really live the rest of
your life being this human being and
yeah what are the things that you're
gonna do to make it happen and change
and if you are truly happy with it then
like you know what are all these things
that are making you feel this way and I
just you know something about the way
that he spoke to me and I you know he
speak he's very harsh I think he's a
maniac but and it doesn't work for
everybody else but that's how I
communicate so it worked well with me
what's crazy is that I think there are a
lot of friends who are concerned
including myself and kind of talk to you
but this random stranger is the one who
inspired you and it clicked in your head
be like okay I need to change my life
and you listen to his podcast as it was
it was his podcast on the Joe Rogan
pocket every single day I listen to that
podcast you warship that pot I listen to
that singular podcast every day when I
walked four to five miles a day for
almost three months just get a random
strangers well he's not a random is this
story was so inspiring you know and it
reminded me of myself and how much I
didn't like myself so I was just kidding
about that but it's been a crazy how I
mean that person has probably has no
idea how he almost he probably saved her
life for sure he has no idea I'm we we'd
it's the ripple effect that he had see I
mean he's probably done it for a lot of
people and I know I would have never
thought either that this stranger on a
podcast could have done that for me a
hundred percent I would have never
thought that but it's kind of crazy how
life works that way right you know how
sometimes it just hits you like that and
you know you yeah the first 30 pounds
you lost her weight you changed a lot
thank goodness you were becoming happier
you just started seeing the the positive
side of the world
you know and he's the most grateful
thing that I have is that we have a
similar diet
oh no more like eating five to seven
tacos every night oh god I hate so many
chuckles yeah that wasn't saying I could
go there once but like you're doing it
every night and now it's like Shama
Shama yeah I hate shopping shopping now
you know it's the people are like oh
well you'll need help you foot know I
eat the stuff that I want I mean
obviously I still want to lose another
like 20 pounds but you know what I have
to forgo in order to lose those 20
pounds is a lot and I'm not sure if I'm
that interested in it but it's more of
like a fun goal for me now if it's if I
do do it is because I'm dedicated
because now it's a challenge the other
stuff happened me losing weight happened
because not so much that was proactive
in losing weight I was just more
proactive and eating better things
because it made me feel good vegetables
fruits whole foods I didn't eat it
because you know it was gonna help me
lose weight I hate it because it made me
feel [ __ ] to me yeah and it like you
want to eat it's not that oh my god I
have to eat this to lose weight more
like I crave pray for those kale and
pray for those yeah it's so I wouldn't
mean Arif I never thought would have
thought that I would crave healthier
food like I crave it like I crave it
like when I was fat I would crave a fat
burger like that's how much I crave
fruits that's how much I crave
vegetables you know just veggies and
meats and then you know simple carbs
because of how it makes me feel after
how I feel when I wake up which is such
an odd thing that I would have never
said that and every time somebody told
me that I go you have been poisoned your
mind has been poisoned I don't know what
your time of hamburgers are good you
sick sick human being hamburgers are
good I just had a number that you made
this week yeah it's friggin good but I
can't have that every day okay so we're
gonna crave for those fibers and veggies
yeah you start to chase a feeling of I
don't wanna say health is just feeling
good that's that's really what it is you
just feel better I think another thing
is one other thing is that we are
getting older and I think our body is
not as you know tolerable with all the
junk food and we're just liking where we
just like these organic vegetables you
know the natural
in our body is just telling us what they
like I think so personally I don't think
it has anything to do with age it's just
us allowing ourselves to really be in
tune with our body right so I was never
in tune with my body I'm I was like
diarrhea that should happen five times a
week maybe yeah but I was just super out
of shape and even now I'm not in the
best shape of my life I'm just a lot
better
I was just that bad and I don't want
anybody to feel I've been fat my whole
life and so sometimes I guess I get you
know some some bigger people when they
hear this they go oh well you know
skinny is not better than fat like
nobody saying that no you know I'm
talking about strictly from a health
purpose yeah you know if we're having
this conversation based on how do you
feel about yourself personally and what
media and society does that's a
completely different conversation we do
that's another podcast I'm just telling
people about how choosing to be
healthier helped improve my mood help
them prove my sleep helped improve my
relationship there's a lot of things
that happen with this and it had nothing
to do with me wanting to look good I you
could even ask Muriel right now I
legitimately thought I looked [ __ ]
cute all the time yeah that's why I'm
saying you would not listen to her
online this guy is just full of himself
I'll let him me and you know some people
wear the weight very well I did not wear
my weight very well at all like I just I
just didn't I know I never really cared
to talk [ __ ] about myself and that maybe
has to go back to how back in the day I
had low self-esteem and I switched that
with a mental flip and I just kept that
energy going and so no matter what if I
gained weight if I just woke up in a
tank top and flip-flops and socks and
shorts and basketball just always
thought I'd look good in no matter what
setting and it kind of at a certain
point started becoming detrimental
because I was 270 pounds almost and I
was just in pain and I just ignored it
because I thought I was fine yeah and
you hated walking oh it was so hard yeah
and you hated walking you just lay in
bed all day as like dude this guy you're
gonna hyper it hi I forgot sorry what
was my brain just stop for a second
but now look at you like you love
walking you know I generally love
walking I love it it makes you feel good
I'm happy for you
yeah well guys well I hope that kind
what I don't know if it really answered
anything about we don't really talk well
let's just kind of wrap this up it's
like how how do you you know end up you
know being vulnerable with your partner
it's just allowing yourself to be hurt
and also allowing yourself to be happy
that's just basically what it is they go
hand in hand
we should do part two of this I mean for
sure uh-huh I mean they go hand in hand
and that's the thing that you really
can't avoid it's just if you're oh if
you're open to feeling this great amount
of love and happiness you have you're
gonna be also opening yourself to be
hurt and that's life and a lot of people
want to delete that part of their life
they want to say I want to be happy
without feeling sad and that's I saying
I want the Sun to rise but never to go
down it's just not gonna happen
yeah something you just need to go for
it and knowing that it might not come
back as what you want but at least you
know that you tried yeah and you know to
to what a lot of people say or I feel
that a lot of people say they go well
what if it happens again what if I get
hurt again that's life homey I know
that's life that's you're not special
that happens to everybody anybody who is
open to being in a relation that's gonna
happen mm-hmm so yeah like if you're
driving out there yunjin accent are you
never gonna drive again oh that's true
you know it's gonna happen but you take
that leap of faith that it's going to be
king or do your best to not get into an
accident and you'll get to your
destination sooner or later yeah
well guys that concludes this episode of
the genius brain podcast where we talked
about being vulnerable with your partner
man that was pretty cool uh yeah I mean
when it comes to relationship stuff I
probably bring Mary along again because
she is my my life partner so life
partner so guys remember uh you can go
to iTunes and give us that five star if
you're on Spotify cast box whatever
we're there to be with you on your
commute and just to chop it up I don't
know what what the topics really are
gonna be until like two minutes before
this stuff but uh hope you guys enjoy
this podcast and I will see you all next
time
peace